youtube as we speak i will verify that
in a second
and redirecting to youtube
and let's see started streaming yep we
are
live i've muted my screen we already
have six viewers
we have six thumbs down that's awful how
could people do that already
um they don't even know how bad this is
gonna be welcome everybody out there we
are letting
the audience trickle in i am going to
ask my guests who have twitter accounts
to tweet out
if you guys can tweet out janna sarah
david
that we are now live on twitter and
facebook
um that would be helpful we'll let
people build up the anticipation
coming into this great debate version
2.0
second millennium edition so welcome
everybody
very thrilled to have so many phenomenal
guests joining us today we have
david spurgle wendy friedman adam reese
jenna levin
uh sarah seeger and myself plus
we have sam singer and uh michael adler
from
a wyoming stargazing association so we
are really
thrilled to have everybody here joining
us we have a lot of people viewing
already
um and i want to thank all my guests
and thank the audience and tonight's
going to be really fun it's sort of
experimental art and we're going to do
our best to
make it through i'm going to send out
the actual link
to everybody on youtube and then we'll
get started with some introductions
so as i said places everybody
and we're going to get started and if
you have a moment there was a
link to register for the giveaways
that'll be
going on uh after the
live stream ends we're gonna have many
many giveaways
of phenomenal signed artifacts from
our phenomenal guests so please
do visit the link that i'll put in the
chat box
in just a second so let me pin that okay
we now have count them
over 51 people viewing but that's going
to go up
so i want to welcome everybody to the
live stream i want to introduce
my friends who have joined me today in
this project that
uh sort of conceived a few months ago
when i recognized that we were in the
100th
anniversary of the so-called great
debate
which is the famous kurdish shapley
debate which solved a little thing or
helped to solve a little thing called
the
size of the universe so we're joined
today
we were going to do some live uh
stargazing unfortunately because of the
weather in wyoming who would have
guessed that in
south central wyoming in november
there'd be bad weather
but nevertheless there are usually great
opportunities for star gazing and i want
to point your attention
to sam singer i'll now highlight him
and he can introduce himself and
describe the mission of the wyoming
stargazing association
and then we'll show uh some images of
their facilities samuel welcome
to the live stream great debate thanks
so much brian thanks for having me
wyoming stargazing is a 501c3 nonprofit
organization
based in jackson wyoming as brian said
and
our mission is to inspire and educate
through
wyoming's extraordinary skies we do that
through
in-person stargazing programs and
more recently virtual stargazing
programs as well as lots of other
indoor presentations so as brian said we
do have a snowstorm tonight we've got
some great images that we've taken
over the past couple months that we're
going to share with you as well as some
cool process
color images done by one of our board
members mike gadler who is also here
with us tonight
yes and that brings me to a description
i'm going to share my slides here
so first of all i have the panel
and then i'm going to show up here uh
and there's the two of us let me share
my screen i'm going to share the keynote
that we prepared with some images that
we're going to be talking over today
so can everybody see that on the anybody
watching on youtube
let us know about that and by the way we
are monitoring the comments so please
provide
live uh chat comments etc so this
recalling
the great debate version 2.0
and uh welcome everybody so the great
debate took place in this facility which
is uh the smithsonian institution in
washington dc which looks a little
different
than it did um over a hundred years ago
when this great debate took place in
april 1920
just to set the scene it was right after
world war ii had ended
it's right after the spanish flu had
sort of claimed
say that again world war one world war
one sorry yes it was
unfortunately a precursor to world war
ii
you see here the headlines of the new
york times
and you also note that the spanish fluid
just barely come to an
end only a few months earlier prior to
the great debate you may wonder
what was this great debate about it
wasn't a presidential election
although there were many many hotly
contested
uh election contestants at that time
warren harding the eventual victor and
his vice president
calvin coolidge i like to point out that
the administration lasted
you know little more than some tv
sessions uh seasons last
uh and that was only about 18 months or
so and so warren harding never got to
hear the outcome of the great debate
which was settled only about three years
after the actual great debate took place
it wasn't settled until 1923.
and we'll try and i'm not sure if your
slides are advancing well they're not
huh
okay let's see here let me see bring
your
sharing is paused
bring your screen to the front stop
share all right what about now can you
see some
okay good so this is the remembrance of
the events i talked about germany
surrendering end of world war one
warren harding running with calvin
coolidge with a song written by al
jolson that's pretty funny
and then they ran against james cox and
franklin d
roosevelt who i believe did have a
successful campaign many years later
uh and then this great debate was held
and i think it really inspires us as
astronomers that this is really the
enduring
takeaway from 1920 was that this
great debate kind of persists in our
memory and whoever was running for vice
president
uh really uh is lost in history at least
unless you're
you know nate silver or somebody like
that so you see
the two gentlemen that we're gonna be
kind of uh talking about heber curtis
and
harlow shapley and we're gonna be
talking a lot about
the telescopes that they used and future
telescopes built in some cases by people
that are on this
uh very live stream uh this is the
hooker telescope and mount wilson
um and uh and it really harkens back to
where do we sit in the universe
and to begin i want to uh sort of
uh start with the man that really
settled this
was edwin hubble but he couldn't really
settle whether or not these smudges
these nebulae
were actually in the milky way or
outside of the milky way this is m51
i think we'll see an image of that from
mike adler's
instruments in just a bit here are some
sketches
herschel observed these and uh and of
course it wasn't until henrietta swan
levitt
took images of the cepheids that we
began to
discover what it meant to measure
distances out beyond the milky way
galaxy
and of course i i can't i'd be remiss if
i tried to explain these data
and i wanted to uh maybe first start off
with um with wendy friedman who has been
known to use a cepheid or two in her day
uh to talk about what did henrietta swan
levitt do
and why was it so important to discover
these mysterious objects called cepheid
variables
so you're gonna go back to henrietta
yeah
that that's her i believe yeah so in
1908 henrietta levitt who was working at
the harvard college observatory
discovered as she was looking at
one of the nebulae the large magellanic
cloud and two of them the small
magellanic cloud
and she found that uh there were stars
in the nebulae and when she measured how
bright those stars
were as a function of time she noticed
that the luminosities of the stars
changed they got dim for a while then
they got brighter then they got dimmer
and they did it in a very characteristic
way
and there had been a type of star known
as a cepheid it had been known for a
couple centuries before that
from our own galaxy and she
realized that the brightness of the
cepheid stars that she had found
had a one-to-one correlation with how
fast they changed in their brightness
so here's her what is now called the
period luminosity relation
and actually recently it's been named
the levitt law
in recognition of her discovery so
the bottom axis shows the
logarithm of the period of variation
these stars
tend to vary on time scales of a couple
days
up to maybe 100 or even greater than 100
days
and then on the y-axis the luminosity is
increasing
as you go up and she's looking at
the maximum luminosity of the stars on
the top here
and the minimum luminosity today we tend
to look at the average
luminosity but the the uniqueness of
these stars the power of these stars is
that once you realize there is this
correlation
if you can measure the absolute or
intrinsic luminosity of a cepheid
in say our milky way galaxy so it's
power it's wattage
then you can measure the
cepheids in a nebula and you can see is
this nebula nearby or is it far away
and so maybe we'll talk about this a
little bit more later you can use
geometric parallax for example to set
the scale
in our milky way galaxy and we're
getting ahead because henrietta levitt
wasn't able to do that
but the power of her discovery is that
you go find these stars they're changing
their brightness
with time you measure their periods you
get a sample them in a galaxy
then you compare them to ones in our own
galaxy for which you know the distances
and then just as you look at a lamp post
in the distance we know that things get
fainter as they get farther away
and they do that in a precise way falls
off as the square of the distance from
us
but cepheis remain one of the most
accurate and powerful ways that
astronomers have today to measure the
distances to galaxies
and that's what edwin hubble did he
found these cepheids
in a few galaxies and now we know as our
local group
nearby galaxies including the andromeda
galaxy
and he was able to show that these uh
stars
in these nebulae based on the cepheid
variables
were much farther than our own galaxy so
they they weren't
actually regions of star formation in
the galaxy which was part of the debate
in the shapley curtis debate so we use
them today
that was one of the main goals of the
hubble space telescope was to be able to
accurately use cepheids to measure the
distance scale
universe which i'm sure we'll get into
more later on in the discussion
yeah thank you very much i love the way
that in old days you know people could
make plots and not label the axes
or label the axes incorrectly so here's
the law so here's uh here is
uh hovel's famous diagram uh i mean
adam david you guys can chime in here if
one of your students turned in
a a plot like this with incorrect units
with no error bars
what kind of grade would she expect to
get
she she'd get it right you got it wrong
brian i i wish that uh
that was only errors that people made in
class back then
i can show you some papers from some of
our colleagues
some famous ones um oh
i know i hope i passed the wrong labels
and see
the profoundness of the result yeah so
adam let's go back to that time i mean
you're a little older than i am but but
not that old um
and when hubble discovered this famous
cepheid in the outskirts i believe it's
on this side here
if you can see my screen he immediately
crossed off the sign that he had made
for a nova and replaced it with
ver why is this so important to get one
single star and
actually i've never known how did he
know this was not a foreground star i
mean what gave him the confidence well
that's a great
those are all good questions um so
people knew about
what we would call novi or even
supernovae which are
you know they're sort of one-time deals
you know they get bright they get faint
that's it so um hubble was
observing this star thinking initially
that it may be anova or variable
but he saw it start to repeat um and so
he crossed that off and realized oh this
is a
variable star not one of these novi and
then he could
as wendy described associate that with
more nearby versions
uh compare their brightnesses and
determine uh that the milky way was
uh yeah i'm sorry the andromeda truly
was far away
um then to determine as you said uh you
know how do you know it was an andromeda
um you know he looked off the field he
looked away and noticed
that he was seeing lots of these cepheid
variables superimposed
on andromeda and not away from andromeda
and so
he realized okay these are certainly in
andromeda
and then at the center of these uh
massive beautiful
spiral nebulae as they used to be known
um and many of them have a heart of
darkness a black hole and
today we're joined with jenna levin uh
who is to be congratulated on the
publication day of her
fourth book uh entitled black hole
survival guide now janna
if we take a journey to the center of
andromeda will we be safe from a black
hole or will we
possibly meet a type of doom that none
of us can imagine known as
spaghettification
well there's there's definitely a black
hole supermassively called the center of
andromeda
it's bigger than ours and um and we're
on a collision course with andromeda
which is interesting
there's sort of a competition between
whether our
star will distend and die
or will collide with andromeda we'll
probably collide i don't know somebody
remind me which one happens first but
but we're we're definitely on this
beautiful collision course with
andromeda and so the expectation
is that the entire solar system will
stay intact
as this happens they'll pass through
each other because the stars are
actually quite sparse
so they'll pass through each other and
then they'll come back and they'll do it
a few times before eventually they
coalesce
and our black holes merge and our whole
solar system
hopefully will stay intact and just be
on some peculiar orbit around this new
supermassive black hole
and again to look look for janna's new
book we did an interview earlier this
morning
on publication day just about the book
and just about uh janna's work in black
holes
so we see here that i think this is a
negative of it i've actually
had the actual plate in my sweaty hands
so they don't let you do that anymore
but i knew one of the archivists
and you can almost feel the palpables
when i was director we still did that
you did that right okay well i didn't
drop it wendy don't worry
now wendy when you see these things like
these light curve that's superimposed
here
this is called v1 in andromeda so
there's a cepheid there
it looks pretty good but i mean could
you you know can
can you say something about the
challenges of modern day extrapolation
it seems like
henrietta swan levitt was heroic as was
hubble in a certain sense and trusting
that the data
um you know to really make this
far-flung association that these
objects are at great distances and then
later that they're receding at great
velocities and we'll get into that in a
moment
but how well do we know the actual how
much has the improvement has there been
in both cepheids and other distance
ladder techniques
yeah so if you look at these data and
you you
you think you know here are cepheids uh
which are faint against the background
of andromeda
right so um it's hard to make these
measurements very accurately because
what you're trying to do is measure a
single star how bright it is but you
have to contend with the fact that it's
in the disk of the galaxy
and then when you think back to what
hubble and and levitt were dealing with
at that time the the um
detectors that we had were photographic
plates they weren't
electronic detectors the charge coupled
devices that we have today that we all
have in our cell phones
similar technology but they were
emulsions
on a glass plate so this original of of
hubbles
and photographic plates were very
inefficient
only one percent of the light coming
from the
the distant galaxies lands on your
photographic emulsion
but worse than that there wasn't a
one-to-one correspondence between the
brightness
and what you measured on your
photographic plate so they had
a lot of issues to contend with
including the fact that they weren't
able to correct for the presence of
interstellar
dust so that's dust that's expelled from
the atmospheres of stars
it absorbs the light that's coming from
your cepheids and it scatters it so it
makes it look fainter
and then you have the earth's atmosphere
to contend with which is why the hubble
space telescope made such a
big difference so yes these measurements
were very very difficult and in fact
hubble got it
wrong by about a factor of seven the
original
value for the hubble constant that he
measured so the hubble constant being
the slope of the relation that you
showed i don't know if you want to go
back to that between velocity
and distance and so i'm not sure we
pointed out to viewers who weren't
familiar with this plot before but what
we were referring to
what what hubble got wrong is that the
units of velocity he put
in kilometers rather than kilometers per
second
and and so you can see there's a lot of
scatter in this plot it's quite amazing
that
the implications of this result so what
he found is that
the greater the velocity of a galaxy
the farther away the galaxy is
and so you could see there's quite a bit
of scatter along that line and that's
because it was hard to measure the
distances
but uh there's no question that there is
a correlation
and the implications of that correlation
were enormous it's what
uh eventually what we came to realize
implied if you took it together with
einstein's general theory of relativity
that um
he had developed in 1915 if a galaxy is
far away it's moving faster from us
or appears to be moving faster from us
and that would imply that there was a
time in the past when
galaxies in fact all matter was closer
together denser
hotter and what eventually led to our
picture of a big bang universe
so the implications of these results
were enormous
even though he got it wrong by about a
factor of seven
and david you pointed out in a
publications of the national academy of
sciences over two decades ago
that you know one of the reasons was
that the reddening of dust
combined with the lack of sensitivity of
the photographic emulsions
made for this um as one of our former
presidents used to say
misunderestimation of uh of the actual
value of the hubble
uh of the hubble constant can you say
something about what was the actual
resolution
uh that caused that caused hubble to get
it wrong by a factor of seven again
i'm not that great an astronomer but i'd
like to think i could get you know close
to an order of magnitude
why did he get it wrong by so much and
why should we have any confidence in
these astronomers who are
so uh graciously of joining us today
that they now know what they're doing to
the sub percent level
well you know i think it's actually
before i get to that
i wanted to actually step back and look
at what weren't wrong with shapley
right because this was the great debate
yeah and
shapley had this argument that a drama
was right near us
and japanese arguments were actually
pretty good
right i sometimes think we look at the
losers in these debates or we look at
you know hubble and say how could they
get that wrong
but these are really good scientists
yeah and sometimes one has an incomplete
picture and you're drawn to wrong
conclusions
so one of the things he saw and this
ties into something we'll
i think talk touch on later is he saw
this there's the observation of this
explosion
as andromedan in the center and it was
so bright so 10 000 times brighter than
uh if you assumed andromeda was far away
it would be 10 000 times brighter than
the novate
we saw in our galaxy it was
one of two possibilities he assumed the
simplest one it was like other objects
we saw an andromeda was close
we later learned it wasn't a novae it
was a supernovae
a whole different class of objects uh
one that adam
and others studied in detail and that
this new kind kind of explosion
the reason it was so bright was that it
was just something we'd never seen
before
and the second mistake was an
observational error
made by a very capable astronomer named
von manning
who thought he had measured the rotation
of andromeda that the whole image that
you see behind me behind you
on the screen was rotated pretty rapidly
and that they thought they had seen some
of the stars
those spots which we now know not a lot
of these bright things are actually star
forming regions
in this this image here um
were appeared to be rotating
and uh i think a lesson from the debate
was people
many people felt that uh well curtis
ended up being right
it was shapley who had the best
arguments
and won the debate and as you noted it
was only later when hubble's data came
in
on cepheids that were things clarified
and so yeah and i want to turn to the uh
to the hubble
uh space telescope but before we do we
should talk about hubble
himself the telescope's namesake who was
reputed to have wanted to have become a
lawyer
and actually went to oxford i believe to
become a lawyer
and uh he actually went through with it
because his dad really wanted him
desperately to be
practicing law and then his dad died i
think in 1913 and he's repeated to say
out upon quitting the law profession and
i know there's many lawyers listening
out there but he's reputed to say i'd
rather be
a second-rate astronomer than a
first-rate lawyer
he certainly turned out to be a
first-rate astronomer and i'm only you
know sort of teasing it's
it's funny that he didn't he didn't
practice law but he has a law named
after him and he has a
he has a telescope named after him as
well and i want to talk about that
with adam there's a picture of it
sitting behind wendy and i'm going to
put that
also on my on my presentation now adam
can you talk about the work that you do
with the hubble space telescope
and then i want to talk about the tess
instrument that sarah led
as well as telescopes in space get above
the atmosphere why is that so important
if uh we're still discussing hubble's
data taken from ground zero
you know from outside of los angeles i
always point out pre-smog
why is it so important to get above the
earth's atmosphere sure well
um if you've ever sat in a swimming pool
and looked out at
you know somebody uh you notice it's
very difficult to see them
well to count how many fingers they're
holding up something like that and
that's the problem we have down on the
ground when we use telescopes
we're sitting beneath an ocean of air
above us that blurs the images
when two points of light that are close
together come to us
they can often merge as they pass
through our atmosphere
and so we don't get these very sharp
images that we need and
uh as was described in order to figure
out how far away
galaxies are we need to resolve or
recognize
individual stars in those galaxies
which is very difficult to do from the
ground
now in the case of andromeda it happens
to be the nearest galaxy and so that
gives you a better chance
to resolve individual stars but as we
find ourselves wanting to
measure much greater distances we need
to be able to
resolve individual stars in much more
distant galaxies so
like looking at your friend who's
holding up three fingers while you're
under the pool
and your friends very far away it gets
harder and harder so
uh there was the clever idea in the
1940s not realized until around 1990
to launch a telescope up into space
sitting above this ocean of
air to get the pristine uh kind of
resolution you can get from a telescope
when the light is not blurred from the
atmosphere and so
with this telescope it is possible to
pick out these
individual cepheid variables that wendy
described
but much further away i would say maybe
40 or 50 times further away than hubble
did
from the ground and if we can look out
further and measure
greater uh distances we can reach out to
some of these galaxies that also hosted
one of these exploding stars that david
mentioned appeared in andromeda
in 1885 a supernova now a cepheid
variable is a very luminous star it's a
super giant star
it's a hundred thousand times as
luminous as our sun
and so we could see them very far away
but a supernova
can be as bright as 5 to 10 billion
times the luminosity of the sun
and so if we use geometric parallax
to figure out how luminous a cepheid is
we can then observe a cepheid in a
galaxy that hosted a type 1a supernova
and figure out how luminous the
supernova is and then we can see
lots of supernovae well out into the
expanding universe
and use that to calibrate how fast the
universe is expanding today
now getting a telescope into space is no
mean feat
and there's one of us at least here
sarah sieger professor at mit
author of one of the books we're giving
away so i want to remind people
in the comments i've got a link to sign
up so you can be eligible to win
both books by professor sarah seeger
professor janna levin her newest book
signed copies
some guy named brian keating has a book
that you can get as well
plus signed papers by wendy friedman uh
on the key project done by the hubble
space telescope which we'll get back to
in a bit
and also by none other than adam reese
the the paper
you know that brought home some swedish
gold it's not showing up super well
anyway
sign up in the in the link i'll put it
another link to it
sarah what's it like uh before a
a telescope launches on a spacex rocket
how talk us through the emotions that
you feel and then what the mission was
about
well first of all it's always a blast
it's always fun to go down to florida
and what's so great about the mission
when you wait for it to launch is you
see
all of your friends and colleagues some
you haven't seen for many years
at the hotel at the beach everyone's
waiting for that really special launch
day
we for the test mission um and typically
if you're on the formal
launch party you go on a bus at nasa and
drive to a site on nasa property
and you know just as the bus was pulling
in we get an announcement
we're turning back now it's um not not
going to launch at the moment
so then you wait because the team has to
figure out what went wrong why isn't
launching
yes and so we had a couple of extra days
in florida and then you go to launch and
it's
amazing but the whole mission everything
you've worked on for so long and i
wasn't working on tests as long as some
other people but
it's all up there in that tiny top of
that fairing
and kind of top of that rocket in the
fairing and you're just kind of keeping
your fingers crossed
but i wasn't so nervous because you're
just sort of caught up in watching the
rocket watching it launch listening to
the loudspeaker
the countdown everything and then it
goes in the sky and it's just one of the
most beautiful like incredible things
ever
i hope you all get to see a launch you
know if you're when we get
back to travel normal new normal anyone
you can see a launch you have to pay
like 50
or something but anything that happens
to be launching when you're there you
can do the official launch but you don't
even need to do that sometimes there's a
better
view along the road or or at the beach
actually
so that's that was the mission then it
it's
not just that's not the nerve-wracking
part but once you turn everything on
you know you wanna show it actually
works properly and yeah it turns out
there's sort of this
huge history that pretty much everything
that you turn on has some kind of
problem
but no one tells you it's sort of
hush-hush and secret so there's no like
lessons learned list you can go to
but as adam and others were saying you
know above the
blurring effects of earth's atmosphere
it's just incredible
and the test mission and you know kepler
before it can do incredibly
precise photometry brightness
measurements as a function of time
but test two it's not just that on earth
that's bad for us
for astronomy for exoplanets it's the
day night
we have here on earth you know like i'm
sure you love daytime
right ryan you want to wake up and have
day and you want to go to sleep and have
night but that's bad for
exoplanets because the transits get
chopped up it ruins your
so-called visibility function of trying
to find periodic events
so tess is in a really brand new unique
orbit it orbits earth
in resonance with the moon it has a two
week orbit about and it goes out to
half the distance to the moon and then
it comes back and it keeps orbiting it's
just so that
when test is at its uh furthest point
from earth the moon is on one side
and the one test goes back to that for
this point the moon is exactly on the
opposite side
and the moon is actually stabilizing the
orbit
allowing tests to look at like a
continuous night sky for for nearly two
weeks at a time
so yeah the test mission is amazing i
just want to say one more thing yeah i
thought you were going to ask me what is
it like to find planets
so i'm about to do that really it's the
most amazing thing ever
to find a new planet and it kind of is
and i hate to kind of say this out loud
but like any job
it gets a little tedious let's say like
it's crazy to say that but
um but you know it's sort of over and
over again same same same same and
every month though it's pretty amazing
that the test mission
finds about a hundred new planet
candidates
so not actual planets but a hundred new
potential worlds
it's it's quite a mission and one of the
ways you do it i'm showing in the screen
now i think it should be visible
is through eclipse of planets that have
atmospheres
and of course you and your team made
some news early in the last month
with a uh with an announcement of
evidence for
the production of phosphine in the
planet
venus's atmosphere and i wonder if you
can comment a little bit on that just uh
first describe what the discovery was
and what the current status is i
understand there is a little
controversy surrounding it currently
yeah sure okay so we've switched topics
completely now yes yes
one of the reasons we don't have i don't
have too much time with you guys i want
to make sure i get it right so we switch
topics we're going to drop exoplanets
now and just let's say
just for a bit of background one of my
main research areas is thinking about
what kind of gases could we find on
exoplanets
in the future when we can study small
rocky planet atmospheres
and one of the gases my team came across
was phosphine it sounds incredibly
obscure
it's associated with life on earth in
oxygen-free environments
and it's not made any other way on this
planet except for us humans make it and
bacteria
almost certainly make it so while my
team had worked on this and put out a
few papers across the pond
out in the uk professor jane greaves
independently
had realized that phosphenus is a good
biosignature gas
and she had purposely set out to look
for phosphine on venus and hence some
mutual contact connected our two teams
and we chipped in to help professor jane
greaves with analysis
with an interpretation of what she found
so
the team announced the detection of
boston on venus a couple months ago
and it was based on two different
telescopes it's a radio telescope it's
um
the james clerk maxwell telescope in
hawaii and the alma observatory in chile
now um we saw the same feature in two
different telescopes but venus being
very bright
and spatially resolved by the way like
would you ever point hubble at venus
okay adam uh wendy would you yeah see
it's too bright it's so bright shadow
okay so i made them laugh
but it's hard to observe really bright
things it sounds ironic doesn't
it like wow i mean if we yeah i mean
it's hard to observe bright things and
it's hard to look for tiny signals
and by the way spatially resolved things
are also challenging so it's a hard
thing all around
now in science in most of these
facilities there's two things i want to
say
including about hubble but in our big
national international facilities
there's two things that are key here
one is that the data is made public so
everyone can
use it themselves and the second thing
and this includes tests as well
is we put out calibrated data for the
users
so i don't know if adam or wendy do you
use the raw hubble data or calibrated
data
sometimes one or the other okay so
with tests i don't think with tests we
give both the raw and calibrated but
it's not detriment so there's a lot of
terms floating around here there's sort
of a basic calibration
that's often done by the facility and
then there's the de-trending the further
data
analysis you do on your own so thanks to
this intense scrutiny
alma the observatory found a problem
with the way they calibrated the data
okay so all the teams that have used the
public data almost all but one
also used the calibrated data they
didn't look at the raw data so most of
those
you can ignore them for now this is a
rapidly evolving situation
so we used the calibrated we had alma
observers alma data scientists on our
team
and it had to do with how they use their
calibrating object i'm not going to go
into too much detail here because we
want to get to some other challenges we
did a podcast also i'll point you
viewers to my channel
uh from yeah but that should include all
this all this latest yeah they can have
the background there
but hopefully you'll come back so it
turns out that
when almost releasing the new public
data that is
like reprocess is i think tomorrow
and so we'll have all the teams can go
back to to bat to look at this
calibrated data
um there's so yeah a few people looked
at the alma data again didn't see
phosphine but we it's an evolving
situation
now the thing i want to leave all of you
with though as it will take some time
for this to play out
is because of our phosphine detection
someone a team of people went back to
look at the pioneer venus data
and we hadn't talked about this on our
podcast and pioneer venus was a mission
from the united states to venus in the
late 1970s that included
different probes and one of these probes
had a special gas mass spectrometer on
it
and when people went back and looked at
this data they actually believe it or
not found quite compelling evidence for
phosphine
and they found um this neutral gas mass
spectrometer ionizes the
gases whatever comes in gets ionized and
then
it's subject to a magnetic field which
eventually depending on the path of the
ion fragment
can tell the mass and the charge and so
they found a bunch of phosphine
fragments including phosphorus
phosphorus ion which there's nothing
else it can be strongly associated with
except for phosphine gas
so yeah the mystery is out there this
could be a debate not right away because
we've got to let things um settle
but with alma jcmt and pioneer venus
now there's three different things to
keep track of for you
sarah what about the other telescopes
data not alma but uh
maxwell yeah so one of the teams that
re-looked at that data
found the signal and then said well it's
not phosphine it's a contaminant there's
only one other possible thing it could
be which is a line of sulfur dioxide
because venus does
yeah this is for like the non-planetary
people there is a lot of sulfur dioxide
but they had to invoke like a huge
amount of sulfur dioxide in order to be
able to match that line
can you talk about the uh the challenges
of doing calibration you you were
responsible for calibrating hubble
uh for some of the work that you did and
then what does it mean first of all to
calibrate
an astronomical telescope don't you just
get you know get it from uh
amazon and go to work now it turns out
there's no um
you know there's no instruction manual
and you do have to calibrate it
so uh there are astronomers who work at
a place called the space telescope
science
institute which is sort of the
headquarters for the hubble space
telescope they run
the process of um receiving proposals
from astronomers what they would like to
observe
awarding time making those observations
but they also hold back
maybe 10 or 15 percent of the
observatory's time
to obtain calibrations and calibrations
are in some ways very boring
but uh they're very essential
observations
to be able to really make quantitative
sense of the images you get so
it usually involves observing certain
kinds of stars
maybe you know their brightness ahead of
time and so you calibrate
the telescope maybe you observe those
stars over the course of 30 years
for hubble and see if the detectors on
the hubble space telescope are decaying
or changing if the field of view is
distorting um
if all the pixels are equally sensitive
or if they're changing over time so
it's a lot of you know i would say sort
of boring but critical measurements so
that
at the end of the day when you apply
these calibrations you get these very
pristine images that you can also do
science with you could also
look at the brightness of a star and
know you know how many
watts you're actually getting from that
so you could compare it to
other stars i wouldn't say that you and
wendy
are our competitors in a certain sense
but wendy can you talk a little bit
about the
hubble space telescope key project to
measure the hubble constant
this paper that we're going to give away
a signed copy of that you graciously
provided
um what what does it rely on is it is it
doing imaging
is it is it really uh relying on these
calibrations that your
your competitor i mean could adam sneak
something in there to make you get a
different result
just kidding you would never do that so
if we were looking at hubble
data early on there was quite a time
where when we made these measurements of
distances to galaxies we weren't getting
them right and you were asking about
that earlier
and and so hubble got this value of 500
for the hubble constant and then
in the 1950s that came down by about a
factor of two
and then it settled into a regime where
some astronomers were saying it was a
hundred and others were saying it was
50. now that's a factor of two
uncertainty
we didn't know the scale size of the
universe to better than a factor of two
and that
that persisted for decades and it in
fact was one of the motivations for
building the hubble space telescope and
it is in fact
the project that led to deciding this
the final size of the primary mirror is
that um
when uh the telescope mirrored the
telescope was being de-scoped it was
originally supposed to be larger than
the hundred inches that it
it ended up it was a 2.4 meter telescope
and that was set by the ability to
detect cepheids in
a nearby cluster called the virgo
cluster
and so when hubble was first flown there
was a concern
that the time would be divided up into
tiny little pieces because every
astronomer had been waiting for this
telescope for decades
and so there were key projects that were
set up there was a peer review committee
that decided what were the most
important projects that hubble and only
hubble could do
and measuring the distance scale was the
the primary project
and so our group competed for god
awarded the time on the hubble space
telescope to try and resolve this factor
of two debate
and so the way we went about it was to
use these same cepheid stars that edwin
hubble had used based on the discovery
by
uh henrietta swann levitt and we
measured the distances to about two
uh 24 galaxies for which we could
make very accurate measurements using
cepheids and tie into other methods
like the type 1a supernovae that that
adam mentioned
that take you out farther into the
hubble flow
and and and we were able to resolve the
discrepancy we got above the earth's
atmosphere
we were able to make corrections for
dust we weren't using photographic
plates any longer
and we had many ways of measuring the
distances independently so you were
asking how did hubble get it wrong
there were about four reasons why it was
really wrong
and largely it was the photographic
photometry and the reddening
but we were able to correct for that so
we got a value of the hubble constant of
72.
now today so you know i've worked on
cepheids for a great deal of my career i
know and
love them but what keeps me up awake is
that there could be
other kinds of what we term systematic
errors
that is there's some kinds of errors if
you make a measurement over and over and
over
sometimes you'll get too high sometimes
too low but you can average over those
and the more times you make the
measurement the better your average
becomes
but there are others that are systematic
in the sense
for example dust will only make your
cepheid look
fainter it's never going to make it look
brighter and so
that's going to take you in one
direction or another
and so that's one thing i've spent a lot
of my career on is is trying to devise
methods for correcting for dust and we
were able to do that
and overcome this problem so one of the
things
as we're approaching now the need for
higher and higher accuracy
what we did with the key project is we
measured a hubble constant to a 10
accuracy so we solved the factor of two
problem
and then adam and and others in the last
couple decades have been
bringing down the uncertainty with time
but now the need for even higher
accuracy is
upon us because we have other means of
estimating the hubble constant
in the early universe which i assume
we'll talk about in a little bit
and so we have a need for even higher
accuracy so one of the things that i've
been doing with my group is to
use a different kind of star than a
cepheid these are stars that are fainter
than cepheus they're older than cepheids
they're red giant branch stars
and um the interesting thing about these
stars the unique property that they have
is they achieve a certain luminosity
and then there's a fundamental physics
limit they they then
become much fainter and they cut off
it's it's um
they don't ever climb higher than a
given luminosity
so they're they're almost a perfect
standard candle we use that term
and the different in the sense than the
supernovae or the cepheids that are
standardizable
they have a luminosity that's that's
constant and you can see them
brian showing here um in the top panel
the white squares are the fields that
we're observing with hubble
again we're using the hubble space
telescope and we're out in the halos
of these galaxies so unlike the cepheids
that are in the
the the giant branch stars they also
occur in the disc but they're
easier to measure in the halos and we
can make the measurements more
accurately
and you can see down below so um
i'm looking now it is harder to see in
the image but
uh there are individual stars in the
circles yeah you can see some of them
um so so they're not uh crowded by the
stars in the disc
and and we can make these measurements
uh really quite
accurately so on the left you can see
the stars in the circles there
so they're they're very simple and both
from a physical standpoint and also from
a measurement standpoint
so we've been recently measuring the
distances in the same way as we do for
cepheids
in nearby galaxies using the hubble
space telescope
we calibrate these stars say with
geometric parallaxes nearby
we measure the tip of the red giant
branch in
galaxies that uh also have type 1a
supernovae and then we
tie into supernovae that are much more
distant
and so the interesting dilemma that we
find ourselves in now
is that what you measure for the hubble
constant
based on these local determinations that
is measurements of stars in the local
universe
when we compare those to what
astronomers are are
measuring based on temperature
fluctuations
in the background radiation from the big
bang
if you use what we now call our standard
cosmological model
to fit the data in the early universe
you can infer what the expansion rate
would be today
and when we compare that to what we're
getting from
the cepheus or the tip of the red giant
branch that value
from high redshift is lower the hubble
constant is about
67 whereas it's maybe 70 or even 74
locally so the the dilemma before us
is is this a significant difference
so if we look at the history there have
been a lot of uncertainties in the
hubble constant
and the answer has been there have been
systematic errors we didn't
yet understand and when we corrected for
them we had a better measurement
so are there still systematics that we
don't understand
or is this a real difference which would
be the most exciting outcome
because what it could mean is that we
are learning something about the early
universe
and the model standard cosmological
model
could have gaps in it we may be learning
about new physics in the early universe
so that's what makes this an exciting
problem it's not yet a solved problem
and in a sense it
may leave us back where shapley and
curtis were
you know maybe some things are right
some things are wrong but we don't know
yet where those are we're at the
forefront and it's hard to see
it's very easy to see in hind's site so
but it's gonna be
exciting yeah david's gone on what is
that
i was just saying david's gone on record
and the sworn affidavit
that he thinks that there could be
systematics lurking and
first of all i want to ask david to
explain what
is the difference between the early
universe cosmology measurements that you
made
with your team and wmap and act and and
other
instruments and planck has now
corroborated and the
late time and why they differ by the
so-called you know five sigma attention
that has gripped the field why is this
important why are these measurements so
discrepant
and you know if you had a bet jana 11's
pet ferret's life
on the resolution what would it be
well there are the way we measure
uh the we measure the harbor constant
indirectly in the early universe
but we're actually measuring in many
ways is the
size of the universe which is related to
the hubble consonant or the distance
really to
out to red shift of 1100 out distance we
look
we're looking at when we look at the
micro background
when we look at the microwave background
we're seeing a pattern of hot and cold
spots
and there's a characteristic size we see
set by the distance a sound wave can
move
so nature's basically holding up a ruler
to us
and we know how the length of the ruler
we think we understand the physics
we think we understand the length of the
ruler and then by measuring the size of
the hot and cold spots
we can infer the size of the universe
and from that if we have the right
cosmological model
to predict what the hubble concept
should be now when we made the
measurements with wmap
over a decade ago and that's the
satellite i was involved in launching
we got a value of around 70.
and with error bars large enough that
was very consistent with the
measurements that wendy friedman and her
teammate
and we really had a pretty consistent
cosmology
um on the microwave background side
there's been a lot of progress since
then
one big step forward was the planck
experiment
uh european-led experiment with
significant components in the us that
mapped the sky an even higher
sensitivity they got values around
67 or 68. there's wmap
so completely consistent with the wmap
numbers and the uncertainties
but now with smaller error bars and a
smaller value
and that's something we've now been able
to check in a number of different ways
so our measurements from chile with the
act telescope
provide an independent way of measuring
the hubble constant from the
microwave background the size of the
universe and again we get a value
bang on the planck measurements and we
combine w map and act
completely independent measurement from
planck we get a very consistent set of
numbers
so i think from the microwave background
i think we're unlikely
to have systematic errors because we've
got independent measurements
making very similar measurements now
sorry numbers now um
you know what has changed since then
since its plot
is has been a reassessment to the holy
cow measurements
and the holy cow values which this is a
based on gravitational lensing another
technique we
haven't talked about but that value is
now shifted down
and is very consistent with the plank
measurement it's really kind of blank
[Music]
i'll debate that a little bit yeah yeah
let's hear it
but that's that's what the people who
wrote the paper said
um and uh you know the pro
they're really i think uh
a couple possibilities uh in terms of
explanations
the most exciting one is that this is
pointing to new physics
one piece of potential in physics that
i've worked on a lot of people are
interested in
is the notion that we've miscalibrated
the ruler
that the we don't that there's physics
going on in the early universe
things happening back in the first say
hundred thousand years the history of
the universe
um that we have not properly included in
our model
it could be dark energy behaving in
interesting ways at
early times it could be interesting new
physics for neutrinos there's a lot of
ideas that people have
been developed that would recalibrate uh
that the distance ladder and perhaps
bring things into better agreement um
that would be the most exciting
possibility the most mundane one
but still important would be that
there's something we're missing in our
understanding
of cepheus that's happened before and
uh you know wendy could say more about
this but her measurements with the
tip of the red giant branch i think is
are also
turned out to be a local measurement
consistent with uh
the planck and w map and at the cmp
measurements
yeah and those are holding up with time
too so we
we have a couple more measurements that
uh we're just finishing up
and that calibration is he's holding up
um and adam you wanted to yeah yeah i
was going to say that um
you know in terms of systematics in the
past
people have thought of specific
systematics that could involve
cepheids like reddening uh or chemical
effects and so
the generation of measurements that i've
worked on the shoes team
specifically addressed those by making
observations
in the near-infrared to sort of look
through the dust
and also by using the same telescope
to calibrate the cepheids and look at
the more distant cepheid so that
flux calibration which we talked about
earlier drops out
and by looking in the near infrared
where chemical abundance effects
are mitigated and so what we've seen
really and it's not just the tip of the
red giant branch
or the cepheids but there are surface
brightness fluctuations there are masers
they're myras there's tele-fischer these
are all different methods we
use um and you know if you look at
the the sort of range of local
measurements it ranges from about 70 to
75
but that full range is above what david
was saying the full range that we see
from the early universe
is really about 67-69 um
the mention of the the lensing
measurements by relaxing certain
assumptions they made about
uh the mass profiles they actually
become quite unconstraining which is
sort of
neither uh informative about the early
universal
late universe and so you know we're in
this position now
where we're trying to figure out okay is
there an error but
is it an error in theory where we are
not understanding
uh the model of our universe so that we
can connect the early to the late
or is it an error in measurements as
people have described a systematic error
and you know we're at the point now the
measurements
are so good i would say on both ends the
early and the late side
that uh we're sort of getting past the
point where people can sort of
wave their arms and say oh new physics
or oh systematic errors
and what we actually need now are
specific ideas
of how uh let's say a
a change in the cosmological model could
match the observation so that we can
test that because it's very difficult
to come up with an idea that's
consistent with the data and likewise
when people suggest systematic errors at
this point
we need a specific mechanism for
how such a systematic error could be
consistent
with the various measurements we've seen
in the local universe and yet
explain the tension we see with the
early universe and so
um you know it's interesting to ask
people you know what do you think what
is your gut feeling but
i'm more interested at this point in
specific ideas
that can be tested because you know
that's how we always make progress
in science is with um you know specific
hypotheses that make predictions really
uh so that we can go out and test those
i mean adam i i just think that he says
the value they quote is 67 plus or minus
4.
that's the same kind of errors that most
of those results you had in that
quote right my understanding was that
they had multiple ways but they're
within two sigma consistent now with
both the
local central values bang on the c
value and they had what they identified
as a problem is something that
many of us have talked about when we've
looked at the previous work which is the
slim
sheet degeneracy the fact that you don't
know how
much mass what the mass distribution is
around
the lenses that they use and what
they've done
is get velocity measurements to
calibrate that and with that
uh a measurement that now seems
consistent uh
that doesn't mean that's the definitive
measurement but i think it's now
the plot that we're being shown right
now is a little
uh i would argue is a bit today was fine
in 2018
but uh in 2020 this shows how things
progress
is now a little misleading the 2020 data
uh for
uh that holy cow value when they
properly account for the uncertainties
and mass distribution
shifts down to 67.4 yeah i'm just
pulling up the paperwork
74 plus or minus 5 and 67 plus or minus
four i guess they have two different
ways of doing it but
i i would agree that it's become
unconstraining now i don't think it
particularly uh answers the question you
know i think this is
sorry you were saying something money
yeah just to add so the carnegie
measurements that are referred to here i
just want to
note that they're based on the the
wreaths at all cepheid distances
too so um if that proves to be an issue
those would be there and the tip of the
red giant branch that we have
land just below 70. so so so
i just agree with david's point both
it's out of date but it also
um you have to be careful what is
calibrating where
and and the holy cow measurements
made an assumption which landed them on
the high end but when you
you get data that can actually constrain
the mass distribution it moved
and the uncertainties went up so i think
we're in play here now and we just don't
know where it's going to land but it's
not as simple as saying
everything lands on one side or or the
other
um and jenna i just want to ask you a
question from the audience just because
i know you have to break off pretty soon
yes sorry i do yeah it's okay uh they
want to know if there's any in the
holy cow results that rely sort of on
the you know gravitational lensing which
is a consequence
of einstein's theory of general
relativity is there a role that black
holes could play in the resolution
are there primordial black holes that
you talk about in black hole survival
guide or
other black holes in the resolution of
the hubble tension or is it just
completely
not relevant well i love that somebody's
trying to drag me into the conversation
but i think i think to a large extent
it's really not relevant but i'm going
to take this opportunity of having
um a minute just to mention how
interesting it is that
hubble lobbied to try to get
astrophysics considered for the nobel
prize
i think he was well aware of the
significance of what he was doing
but astrophysics was not considered
under the physics nobel prize for
for decades afterwards and i think it's
also
really well for people to realize that
at the time that einstein was working
and that his friend writes him a letter
from the russian front to
propose this thing that we now call
black holes einstein
did not know there were other galaxies
out there i mean that's just tremendous
in 1916
and so so for hubble to just have that
realization
that these objects are outside of
yourself it just it's it's
it's what why you started this this
whole thread with all these brilliant
people on this call is because
you know our concepts went from this to
like whoa
right suddenly the universe was bigger
than that so
i wanted just to mention that piece of
history because i think that's quite
interesting i don't think it was until
and i'm sure wendy probably knows about
jocelyn bell
who was overlooked in principle for the
nobel prize for the discovery of pulsars
that was the first
that went to anthony hewitt um was the
first nobel prize in astrophysics and of
course
now we just had the announcement in
october
that uh the nobel prize went for for
black hole astrophysics and so that was
very exciting the discovery of
supermassive black holes but the other
really cool piece of history i want to
mention was about henrietta levitt
that was just a phenomenal story it's
not just her
so she was a member of a group of women
that were
called pickering's harem unceremoniously
called pickering's haram charles
pickering was the director
of the harvard observatory at the time
and he had a bunch of male astronomers
working for him and he got so fed up
with them
that at one point he said my scottish
maid could do a better job
and he fired them all so the story goes
i actually am not a historian so i'm not
sure this is exactly it
and he hired his scottish maid
wilhelmina fleming
and wilhelmina fleming oversaw henrietta
levitt and all of these
female astronomers who worked for 25
cents on the dollar
and i mean they were they were
absolutely impoverished
some of them had problems like we're
going deaf they were
you know they were going to love it did
go deaf yes
it went deaf i mean it's a trend and the
glass plates
are stunning that wendy referenced and
there's this whole history of
of this pickering's harem who collected
these glass plates
and i don't know if the harvard observer
has retained them because there was some
discussion of destroying them because
they didn't know how to house them
properly
but the history of that story is really
it's really
very moving and pickering actually
treated um
these women i think with with a great
deal of respect under the context of the
time
right in the context of the time this
was he he was doing his best
he and i think they cared about him very
much but they they
they were frustrated that they were so
desperately underpaid that they were
actually struggling in total poverty and
some of them were taking care of mothers
and children and
um but um but but the story
you know that davis sobel uh wrote a
book
called the glass universe about um
pickering's harem and it's very
interesting last thing i'm going to say
before i jump and i let
and i let these folks who are actual
astronomers talk about data which i
find really exciting to listen to by the
way even though
it's not you know i don't touch data i
love hearing about it um
the the the the thing that um i want to
mention about david sobel
and and the glass universe was that um
it really it's it's people shouldn't
rewrite history in this way
i've noticed that if you now go on to
some of the old
like wikipedia pages they no longer want
to say pickering's harem because they
find it slightly offensive
and they no longer want to say what
pickering actually said which was my
scotch made
and but it's very important that we
remember these things because we have to
understand
the reality of what the context was and
how tremendous it was
that um henrietta levitt did what she
did and how important it was that hubble
used that
and and used the science and
and that exactly that plate that you
describe brian where he crosses
out nova and he puts in var
exclamation point that's the epiphany
so i just oh there you have it there you
have it actually dave has agreed to come
on my show
and uh into the impossible podcast i
just want to say one more thing about
shapley because i think there was a
human element he was the director
uh curtis was the director of the
alejany observatory allegheny observator
which is part of the university of
pittsburgh
and um and then shapley was at mount
wilson
where hubble made the measurements that
would later you know cast
doubt upon what the claims that shapley
made and basically turn in favor of
curtis
um but actually i read that he was
almost angling for a job
of becoming the director of harvard
college observatory
that that was why he looked at the
debate as his job interview talk
yes yes so wendy do you can you say more
about that like the the human element of
it all
yeah well and there's another aspect of
this which is really fun part of history
which is
so yes uh shapley was at mount wilson
where hubble was and george hillary hale
and there is a there's a story that um
alan sandage actually
uh said to me was true so i don't think
it's just apocryphal
it was that uh shapley had photographic
plates of
the andromeda galaxy and one of the
really interesting pieces of history was
that
at that time when mount wilson when the
telescopes were being built there
weren't paved roads and there weren't
cars when the 60-inch was being built
and they used mule trains to bring up
the telescope tube and bring up
uh what they needed to build the
telescope and one of the mule drivers
was a
man by the name of milton hummerson and
he turned out to be and i want to say
more about uh wilhelmina fleming and
henrietta 11 after this too two janice
uh related to this but but he ended up
first working as a janitor on the on the
mountain and then he became an assistant
to chapley and to hubble and as the
story goes
he was developing photographic plates
for harlow shackley
looked at the andromeda galaxy and could
swear that he saw variables and he
walked into harlow shapley's office and
said
i think there are cepheids in the
andromeda galaxy
and because shackley was convinced that
that couldn't
possibly be true because that would have
meant that
that these uh nebulae were outside this
big milky way that he was arguing for
he took his handkerchief and rubbed off
the places that
hummus had marked where the the
variables were
and lost his chance to make the
discovery of uh extra galactic nebulae
so that
and then he later hired uh celia payne
gavin
i can never pronounce her name oh
cecilia payne and she actually did she
was the first woman to get a phd at
harvard so henry had 11
and that group of women that pickering
hired they were not
allowed to get degrees at harvard at
that time and willabina fleming had been
a high school teacher in
in scotland when she came over
apparently the story is
her husband had deserted her i believe
she was pregnant at the time so she
ended up working as pickering's maid
and he realized this was a woman whose
talents were you know
being totally lost and hired her and she
turned out to be a superb
manager of this group and uh
people like henrietta levitt and annie
jumped cannon i mean there's just a huge
number of women in this
harem as it was called um who did
fantastic astronomy but they were never
granted degrees
and they were paid egregious wages as
janna pointed out
and um fortunately the situation has
changed wilhelmina fleming
i do love that you know we need to
preserve that history because it is it
is a
it's a it's a layered and complicated
story and
and it really is what launched this
field
and um you know i think we have to
remember that i think we have to
remember
that scientific integrity it's really
important that it
you know hubble hubble didn't scoff at a
woman's work and therefore not use it
right
right so um so this is elizabeth
apparently was nominated for a nobel
prize but she died she
died before hubble's discovery of
galaxies and before
of course his discovery of the expansion
she never realized the implications of
her own work which is just sad she she
died very early
it set up the astronomy department at
harvard
so that he could give sicilian phd
really oh yeah
she's the first astronomy phd at harvard
because the physics department wouldn't
give a phd to a woman
um david i thought that was also true of
harvard that the first phds were from
pickering param
in astronomy for for similar reasons
that that it did they just kind of
created a new phd program
to confer ph is that not true wendy not
true they were not
granted one of them it's not annie john
cannon
i can't remember who started the vassar
college observatory
i'm struggling to remember now anyway i
didn't mean to derail the conversation
it's fascinating i just i do have to go
speaking
i do have to go but i'm going to listen
on my way out
to pick up my children i'm going to
listen and um
i want to get back to the data because
that's that's a really great stuff yeah
i want to get to the imaging too
janet thank you so much congratulations
again on the publication of black hole
survival guide it's one of our gifts
we'll be giving away
there's still time to register uh for
the giveaway i'll put the link
in the thing and while you're at it
exercise your finger i always say make
sure those finger muscles are working
and
subscribe to the channel hit the
notification bell if you would
and you will get access to more great
content like you heard i'm going to have
david sobel
i'm going to have sheldon glashow on the
show next week and
lenny suskind and many other people in
addition to all these
wonderful guests that i've had on so far
so let's keep going
i want to get to data i want to get to
imaging bye janet thank you so much
congrats again on an awesome awesome
book
um i want to go to the our wyoming star
gazers who are snow gazing tonight
and they graciously sent us some images
of what the capabilities of their
observatory
is is able to make and i want to
zoom in here so we'll start with this um
hopefully this video will play i don't
know sam is this a video i'm gonna try
to play
it's a youtube video yeah youtube video
okay so it's gonna ask me to link to a
youtube video
okay um well i don't know if i can
actually get that going and not lose the
uh lose the stream here but i want to
look at uh
ask mike to describe some of these
images that are shown here there's
hubble images
and they're shown next to images made
from wyoming stargazing
and obviously you know hubble has
certain advantages but
it is true that we can do an awful lot
from the ground and we will have some
uh examples of citizen science that
people can participate in if they're
interested so
mike can you talk a little bit about the
facilities at your observatory that
we're looking at
okay yes um these pictures were not
taken by my
uh i didn't take these pictures the ones
that are going to come later are but
my observatory uh which is in jackson
hole
uh is uh uh has three telescopes in it
one of which
is a uh 20 inch plane wave telescope
and uh these two this these pictures are
in fact are taken by
uh the 20 inch plane wave i also have a
six inch
uh takahashi refractor and i have a 12
and a half inch
plane wave and i use these telescopes uh
depending on
the object if the object is a small
object like
for example the pillars of creation
which we're looking at here
i would use the 20 inch but for example
the andromeda is real
nebula galaxy excuse me is quite large
and it's about six moon diameters in
size there's
that's where the six inch telescope
comes in display because it has a much
larger field of view
and then i for the uh uh moon in the sun
and uh planetary nebula uh planetary
observing
i use my 12 and a half inch telescope
and they are all in the same observatory
right now they're getting snowed on
outside
uh i have we had a great summer here and
a lot of beautiful nights
um uh before this smoke from california
came in
now yeah we are definitely plagued by
the atmosphere
um uh samuel you're going to also talk
about
some of those uh the plan i don't know
which we want to start with the
planetary pictures or these deep space
pictures
let's go to the either one yeah let's
look at the nebulae and then i want to
get back to
some of the discussion that we have but
for yeah actually let's look at the juno
image i want to talk about that i want
uh sarah to jump in here
with um some commentary on opportunities
for
citizen science as mike's doing here but
first mike can you tell us a little bit
about the junocam
images that you're showing here that you
processed you didn't take these these
aren't taken from my
no no no i didn't i certainly didn't
take them but the junocam
uh project uh on the uh juno satellite
was really left to uh amateurs to
process the pictures the
the cameras was taking these raw raw
pictures
uh and uh was left to amateurs and i i
uh
being an amateur i was fascinated by
some of the pictures other folks had
done and i i
developed i put together these pictures
like the one on the left
actually has won an award in wikimedia
as one of the five
uh best science uh photographs
uh images of the year it's uh of the
south pole and it was
is a composite of pictures that was
taken during the first
third and fourth of the orbits that the
juno satellite
satellite made um and it was complicated
because there wasn't a lot of overlap
between the
the pictures so i had to uh do a lot of
hand
uh hand work to make that picture the
one on the right
was taken during the 18th
orbit and it involved four separate
pictures
taken at different uh at different
distances from the planet so it was
quite a job
assembling them into a single picture
because i had to correct for the
difference
in uh in the uh distances but
they both came out beautifully and it
just of course the satellite is quite
close
uh compared to even the hubble there's
resolution here in these pictures
that are beyond uh even the hubble uh
images because the satellite
gets as close as uh uh
several thousand miles uh to the uh
to the to jupiter when it's at its
closest now
when it's passing over the pole like on
the left picture
it's about a hundred thousand kilometers
away the one on the right on the average
it changed
during the four pictures i had to use
but on the average it was about twenty
seven thousand kilometers away
taken from a uh a direct
taken from forty degrees south uh so you
can see the
giant red spot uh on on the upper uh
corner
and you can see some of the same parts
of the image
um uh that we're seeing on the left uh
at the very bottom so you're seeing the
south polar region as well
now sarah can you talk about there's um
i found online the american association
of variable star observers
has a link to opportunities for
folks to help with analyzing test data
can you talk a little bit about
opportunities for people that might be
listening uh to get involved with
actual research conducted by
professional astronomers
yes actually you can also google on
planethunters.org and it will relink you
to a website for crowdsourcing
and what the mission does is the people
who organize this they take test
public data and they chop it up into
pieces and you can train yourself on a
tutorial on how to find
planets by the transit method and it's
actually highly successful every year
there's
a couple a few maybe planets found by
crowdsourcing that the professionals
missed
oh wow yes i'll have a link to that uh
in the in the comments in just a second
uh
really good okay so uh let's look at one
more
uh slide here from mike's images and
then
we'll get back to um we'll get back to
some great debates but i do want to talk
a little bit about novae
uh and so forth so um we lost our black
hole uh
expert but um i want to talk about these
images
and as well as what they you know what
they may pretend for
for settling these future great debates
if we have
opportunities i'd like to know uh
actually since we still have uh sarah's
attention
can you talk about the next you know
upcoming missions that you're involved
with
you know building on the test legacy
first of all there's so many missions
my favorite mission is actually this i'm
leading a
helping i'm leading a concept study on a
mission to venus
where we would look directly for signs
of life and for
for life itself we have a small medium
and large mission we're studying
small we're going to partner with rocket
lab who are planning
to go to venus they already have funds
and plans to send a small rocket to
venus which would have a very small
payload and we're helping choose the
science instrument
but back to exoplanets everyone's
waiting for the james webb space
telescope to launch
in fact proposals for the first cycle
are due in a couple of weeks
and i bet every exoplanet astronomers
working hard
we want to study planet atmospheres and
maybe it's going to be big
david can you say more about what james
webb will do and what its prospects for
launch and and so forth the challenges
thereof
well james webb is the most complicated
in many ways uh engineering and science
project ever launched
it's this incredible telescope that will
be
much larger than hubble and because it
operates in the infrared able to stare
much deeper in the sky
and i think it's going to have
significant impact on
many of the questions we've talked about
you know
when you could say more about this but
for things like tip of the red giant
branch
the fact that you've got a powerful
telescope observing in the red
or the infrared that has much higher
resolution than hubble
will uh enable us to use those
techniques to go much further out
and that may be one of the things that
you know i think for this hubble uh
discrepancy
uh it is having new types of data is
going to be the way we'll make progress
and hope then one of the things jwst
will give us
is new types of data i think it will
also have enormous impact
on our study of planetary atmospheres
um sarah seeger spoke of the test
mission and tess is finding
planets that transit in front of their
host stars
those planets will be targets for the
james webb space telescope that will be
able to observe
basically sort of uh before and
during and after images so you'll watch
the spectrum
of the star before as the planet moves
in front
and afterwards and that will
enable the detection of of
the properties of atmospheres around
other planets around other stars
so that will be that's among the things
we're all excited about with the
the james led space telescope yeah i was
just browsing the um
guaranteed time observer projects today
like if you have
built an instrument or have some other
special role you get time like
guaranteed for you
you don't have to propose actually and
there's so many transiting planets
already in those lists so we'll be
seeing results probably among some of
the earliest results
we might hear about are about transiting
planets oh it's really exciting
yeah i can't i think every time we made
real progress it has been
jumps in our technology technology has
improved these since we saw it with
the debate in the hubble constant uh
last time
then you get above the earth's
atmosphere and you suddenly have this
capability you didn't have before and
you make real progress and i think
uh yeah we're really looking forward to
a new instrument that's
uh sensitive to the infrared and has
higher resolution
because we will be able to push farther
out with the tip of the red giant
i have um so we have about 10 minutes
left and i do want to get the questions
but adam sent me some fresh data
this is fresh has plots from very uh out
of data plot there before
which uh so uh this is a compilation i
didn't do this but this was
a paper last week um so this sort of
shows
the most recent measurements maybe in
the last two years or so
uh and what we were what is labeled here
is indirect is what david was referring
to
uh observations from the causing
migraine background and the cosmological
model used to predict the value of the
hubble constant
and that kind of peach orange looking
band is sort of where those
measurements prefer and then uh below
the dotted line is the
the direct and so those are the local
measurements and the various techniques
that
we've discussed in this um um
the cepheids the tip of the red giant
branch myras mazers
tully fisher and uh i mean you can see
the
the issue here really quite clearly i
think is that uh
there seems to be an offset between uh
these two sets of things
it doesn't really look like um the
direct measurements are drawn
from the that peachy kind of uh
band uh and certainly there are some
variations there's some noise here
um but um you know as we try to
make this comparison and convince
ourselves we really understand the
universe
from the beginning to the end you know
this is not a very convincing
uh result of that um so certainly you
know more measurements
uh and and better techniques uh but
you know as i was saying before it'd be
really valuable uh if people have
specific ideas
of what is in common with the
measurements
either on the direct side or the
indirect side that could cause
one group to shift with respect to the
other i mean you know we could always
sort of pick our favorite measurements
but
you know that doesn't really uh give us
a working hypothesis of what produces
this
difference we see um i don't know if uh
and david the the
the barrier uh lensing measurement is at
the bottom there so i think that's the
one you were referring to
um but i don't know david if you have an
idea of like
what could be in common with uh these uh
that could be a systematic even
though i mean the things that i've
looked at most
are the lensing and i was really pleased
on the these measurements to see the
error analysis which i think is superior
and does include the uncertainties in
in the mass profile and what are the
assumptions we make in the indirect ones
and we've been looking very closely at
things like neutrino interactions and
one of the interesting features that has
it makes
clear predictions about what the
microwave background fluctuation should
look like on small angular scales
so we're right now doing an analysis
where we're taking the data we've
measured from chile
and asking could we change our
cosmological model
and in doing so change shift where that
peach curve would be
because all of those techniques assume
we know the length of the ruler
so if we can change the length of the
ruler that's the way we would shift the
peach curve
um i think on the you know the purple
curve
uh you know with uh
you know uh tip of the red giant branch
um
numbers you know lie somewhat in the
middle
um and with cepheids i mean uh
you know we uh
i think well our best hope is if we have
with james webb we will have more data
higher quality data
and we'll either confirm those numbers
and the error bars will get smaller
or we might discover something new about
their properties or some
subtle effect that we've missed in the
past one of the exciting missions that
we haven't mentioned really that
actually relates quite directly to this
is a european mission called gaia
which is measuring the parallaxes of
billions of stars
and in particular are is measuring the
parallaxis of some of these
star types that we use to measure
distances and so
gaia is due to have their data release
three in three weeks i think
that will be very exciting uh moment
because uh
that should could uh give us the kind of
precision
that we need to truly reach a one
percent measurement uh
locally in the direct measurements of
the hubble constant um you know
one never knows what to expect you know
when a new data release comes out from a
new
facility you know how it will
recalibrate things but that is certainly
something to
keep an eye on one of the cool things
gaia did
was they i mentioned early on this
vodman result
that was an attempt to measure the
distance to andromeda by looking at its
rotation
and van moden got it wrong but gaia had
the precision to finally be able to
measure that effect at that distance
and uh so rotational parallax rotational
parallax
not at the precision needed to really
tell us something about this question
but it's kind of cool that yeah it took
a hundred years to do the von monde
measurement right
well that's where curtis was right he
just didn't believe
that that valmond could make a
measurement that small
but curtis was actually wrong because he
didn't believe that cepheids could be
used to measure distances
so there were a lot of who won that
debate they both won
in some ways and lost in other ways
which i think is a good lesson for the
present
i also wanted to jump in and uh uh
defend one other aspect of hubble's
original measurements you know we talked
about
you know some kind of systematic errors
there were also two generations
of stars so-called pop one and pops two
stars
and a you know not realizing that fact
but actually
uh calibrating the luminosity of one
type locally and then observing the
other type far away
and not realizing those were actually
two different types of stars
that led to those populations right so
one of our viewers is asking what makes
them pulse in the first place
and then why are what makes them diff
the two different populations of cepheid
pulse of different properties
right well so cepheids uh like all stars
are have a an exquisite balance between
gravity crushing the star
and a kind of thermal pressure all the
heat from the star pushing back and
that's called hydrostatic equilibrium
normally a star sits right there in that
perfect balance but
there are mechanisms in stars in
particular
in their atmospheres that cause stars to
overshoot that sort of like
uh you know kids sitting on a swing can
sit happily you know at the bottom of
the swing
but given a little push will go back and
forth and in the case
of uh the cepheid variables there's um
an element of their uh atmosphere that
causes a greater opacity and can
push like somebody pushing on the kid's
swing that started to become a little
bit bigger
and then at that point uh gravity starts
to win as the star cools off and then it
shrinks again and then it overshoots so
it's a it's a kind of instability that
causes this constant overshooting around
equilibrium
and then the two different populations
that he was um unaware of
so that that you know in the first
generation there was not a lot of what
astronomers call metals which is really
just means anything
heavier than hydrogen or helium and so
stars had a somewhat different
composition than once a generation of
stars
uh was able to fuse heavier elements in
its core
and then spew those elements out into
space through supernova explosions
gravity sweeps up those heavier elements
and the next generation of stars
still mostly made of hydrogen but now
have trace
amounts of these heavier elements and it
can subtly change
the properties of stars it can change
their luminosities and colors a little
bit so those are things that
astronomers now know and calibrate but
did not uh
know back in hubble's time and these
other population stars are actually
lower mass and older stars than the
population two
cepheuds so they're they're less
luminous they're a completely different
beast wendy someone's asking you in the
chat room
about our tip of the red giant branch
star is more immune to
certain types of systematic errors
intrinsically not
by virtue of the fact they're on the
outskirts of the galaxy
yeah i think there are some reasons that
they are
um i think they're they're simpler in
the sense that
as i mentioned they don't get brighter
than
a certain luminosity and so these are
stars
um they're solar mass or so
um when they exhaust the hydrogen in
their core
um and then they begin to collapse the
central parts of these stars become
degenerate
they're they're supported by electron
degeneracy pressure
and then they have a hydrogen burning
shell and the stars
ascend what we call the red giant branch
temperature is
increasing until it reaches about a
hundred million degrees
and then you have enough so that then
you can start to burn
helium stably um and the star
the degeneracy is lifted the star no
longer
is at that luminosity it rearranges
itself and falls onto what we call the
horizontal branch
and so the physics of that is very well
understood and people have been modeling
that for decades
it's extremely well understood physics
all the models predict this
and and so we don't have to worry about
pulsating atmospheres
the the um metallicity of these stars
that we've been talking about any
elements
that are heavier than hydrogen and
helium are reflected directly
in the temperature or the color of the
stars that we observe
with the cepheids adam mentioned before
that we can make corrections for the
metallicity and this is something that
in fact
um uh i and a collaborator barry madore
devised very early on was to look at the
the abundances in the gas
near the cepheids sepias are too faint
to measure their abundances
directly you have to get spectra to
measure their abundances
so it's a proxy it's not a direct
measure of the metal abundance whereas
for the red giant branch stars we
measure the color
two filters that's all we need and we
know what the metal city is
it's a it's it's a one-to-one
correspondence we know what the
luminosity is we know what the
metallicity is
and uh we don't have to worry about
pulsations
when we're out of the halo we don't have
to worry about dust and so
i i think there are many reasons that
um they're less complicated and what
still concerns me about the cepheus is
yes we can make corrections for
reddening and that's something in fact i
did in my phd thesis when we first were
able to get
uh ccd detectors and get
multi-wavelength photometry
and then ultimately with um
two-dimensional in-red detectors to go
out into the infrared
you measure the extinction really well
but the worry is because of this
difficulty when the stars are in the
centers
or in the disks of galaxies it's hard to
measure their brightnesses
as you're pushing farther out in
distance so you've got
potentially the stars are being crowded
and blended with other stars
particularly in the infrared and the
sort of nasty part of this is it's the
red giants that are doing the crowding
and blending
as you go to the infrared so you're
trying to simultaneously
correct for the metallicity which may or
may not be reflected by the young
gas phase trying to correct um
for the reddening and trying to correct
or at least estimate what the crowding
effects are so you have to do this as a
system
and maybe each of these effects is only
one percent or so
but maybe together collectively they're
a bigger effect than you think
so i gotta
measure the tip of the red giant branch
stars is you won't
get to the bottom of these kinds of
effects doing one type of measurement
alone so the cepheids are what they are
um
but we're pushing them out so you know
hubble increased our resolution but the
farther out you go
you lose that um advantage of the
resolution of hubble
so that's why i think we need to take
the next jump yeah
jump in here and defend the cepheid so i
think the elegance of the cepheids is
you know every individual cepheid gives
you
a distance and so when we look in a
distant galaxy we don't just get the
distance to the galaxy we get many
hundreds of measurements of the distance
and so
you get to check this sort of internal
consistency uh you know one of the
challenges i think really of the typical
what's up with the red giant right
with the tip of the red giant branches
there is no such thing as a star that
is the tip of the red giant branch it's
a feature
a break in the luminosity of many stars
and so you have to correctly measure
where that break is you don't get a
cross check you don't get many
measurements you just get sort of one
shot at that and
you know when you have many
it's very difficult to actually see you
know have i properly measured the break
or have i measured
a kind of ripple in the luminosity
function and so
i think that you know as we uh you know
are able to move to the near infrared
uh particularly for cepheids to get
through the dust and
observe many of them i think we've
gotten very clean measurements i
you know at this point i think you know
it's hard to beat cepheids in terms of
their range
and their repeatability
slightly beauty adam in the sense that
we have hundreds of stars in some cases
thousands that define the tip and so but
you know
from any one of those stars you know you
have to look at all of them just get one
number from that yeah so uh we gotta
wrap up because youtube is uh closing
down on us actually at one point they
had a
they had a warning and it said go to
wikipedia if you're concerned about flat
earth debates so
i don't know we can agree on a flat
universe yeah we're being shadow band
but i want to ask all of you in the
remaining precious moments that i have
uh with my friends and colleagues we'll
start with sarah
um what uh and not in your field
are you most interesting in discovering
if you can come back in a hundred years
or you keep taking your vitamins
uh and and you and you live to be 100
years older
when you come back in the 200th
anniversary of the great debate
what thing will you most want to know if
you're coming out of suspended animation
what other outside of your own field
what would you like to know most of all
in 100 years
well i think mine would be pretty simple
i'd like us to have images of the very
first
objects that formed in the universe
you know the james webb is supposed to
see back to first light i don't know if
it will but i think i'd love to just
know what what really happened
in an image not in inferred information
very nice
and uh let's go to david what would you
like to know
most of all outside of your particular
field of expertise
what uh what what fact would you most
like to know
in the year uh 22 21 20
are we alone
are we alone in the universe fascinating
great how about you adam outside of your
field outside of
uh the very fascinating subjects that
you study what are you most fun to know
yeah well uh i you know i would like to
know what dark energy is we haven't
talked
too much about that but uh you know that
is extremely interesting
um i'm i i had a second on my mind also
to know what
ligo the gravitational wave facilities
actually what the census of the universe
in the dark sort of
yields uh variants in that
and wendy what about you what outside of
your field would you most be curious to
know
the answer to in the year 2120 yeah i
think i'd have to say too i i'd like
unambiguous evidence it is their life
elsewhere
um and i think that's going to be a
fascinating field to break open
thanks and then sam and not just
bacterial life yeah not not slime mold
you want
bach not bacteria uh sam singer
uh director of the wyoming star gazing
association thank you for sharing your
time
what would you most like to know the
answer to outside of your field of
expertise
uh i'm with david and wendy um
not just a detection of you know
one form of life but how many
intelligent civilizations are out there
and michael last but not least thank you
so much for sharing your images
uh what would you be most curious to
know the answer to in the year 2120
well i'd like to know the answer to this
debate
for one thing you know because uh this
debate is fantastic has been very
interesting
and uh what it and and also what is dark
matter what is dark energy
very good well i do want to thank all my
uh illustrious guests i
thank you so much from behalf of me my
audience etc
i want to remind you all to please
subscribe to my channel dr brian keating
on youtube
but also to subscribe to the wyoming
star gazing association's channel we're
trying to get them
over the 100 subscriber mark tonight so
hopefully people can do that i put that
link
also in the chat sign up for the
giveaways so that you may too
uh win a copy of either uh jenna levin's
new book black hole survival guide
sarah seeger's wonderful book uh she
promised to come on the into the
impossible podcast for a solo episode
the smallest lights in the universe um
losing the nobel prize which you can get
anywhere books are discarded adam reese
signed copy of the paper that brought
him
up on ebay yeah i better not well i want
to see who got more you or wendy
because wendy's uh lovely paper uh the
hubble key project
uh is also signed and available to uh
two guests will win
one of these are there two people in
each one of these each one of these
one copy of each of these books david
you're going to send me a beer cozy you
promised that you signed
or something like that something else
that's cozy maybe
i want to thank everybody so much this
has been so spectacular i hope we can do
it again in 100 years
uh but even before then i hope we can
all get together we should be well
and enjoy many great debates like this
and contra distinction to the political
debates
these are done with great committee and
comedy and
i had a wonderful time i can't thank you
all enough have a wonderful evening
good night